it's a new day back to work it will not  be listening to no orcish music that is  one of the greatest love songs ever  written yeah well I feel sorry for work  ladies  oh we had Amnon show us in roof first  time being shot at I just liked it very  much  yeah it sucks  the new killer weapon that grants wishes  I'm assuming this doesn't end well  I'm a warrior a priestess a lover  I am whatever I need to be this falls  into the wrong hands  the whole world is in danger it'll teach  doubt of the Academy no they do not  we're gonna put an end to it  I thought you were dead I'm had too many  bills to pay  I'll take the little homie out LAPD  style like you do ferry lives don't  matter today  you  you